this month both richard branson and jeff
bezos made brief yet successful trips to
space
the two billionaires flew above the
earth's surface with their respective
companies
virgin galactic for branson and blue
origin for bezos
branson was the first to go of the two
on july 11th
launching from a site in new mexico
shortly after 10 30 a.m eastern
virgin galactic's plane vms eve took off
carrying the spacecraft vss unity and
its passengers
the successful space flight took branson
and his crew over 50 miles above the
earth's surface
this also marked the first time a
billionaire went to space using their
own spacecraft
a little over a week later on july 20th
jeff bezos and his crew
took off from a site in texas around 8
12 a.m
central daylight time shortly after the
launch the capsule successfully
separated from the booster rocket
which sent the crew on a 10-minute
flight which reached its apogee over 62
miles above the earth's surface
the capsule landed safely back on earth
a short time later
while both billionaires were ecstatic
about their successful flights
critics on earth have pointed out the
large investments on space travel
at a particularly vulnerable time for
humanity with the coven 19 pandemic
historic heat waves and flooding and
concerns that global warming
has reached a dangerous new level the un
has also repeatedly warned of widespread
famines
in poorer nations as a result of the
pandemic
according to un world food program
executive director
david beasley six billion dollars would
be needed to save 41 million people
worldwide
set to die of hunger this year alone
beasley urged branson bezos and elon
musk
to come together to tackle this
challenge there is also a concern that
the shift of space travel from the
public sector to private
has simply made a tourism industry which
only caters to the ultra wealthy
to put it in perspective one of the four
seats on the blue origin flight with
jeff bezos
was sold at auction for 28 million
dollars
you